Привет! В этом модуле мы прошли уже много шагов: генерация, поиск стилей, промптинг,
джейсон, апскейл, видео и так далее. Каждый раз это была цепочка действий, и каждый шаг ты делал
отдельно — в своём окне, руками, в отдельных генераторах, возможно даже. Нодовый подход собирает
такую цепочку в один управляемый граф в одном месте. Возможно, звучит сложно, сегодня посмотрим,
как всё это выглядит и как всё это собирать. Смотри, в чём идея? Обычный промпт — это, можно сказать,
чёрный ящик. На вход ты даёшь текст, на выходе получаешь картинку, а что происходит внутри — не
видно и нормально не поправить, если, конечно, мы джейсоном не пользуемся, именно для этого я тебе
его и давал, чтобы хоть какую-то долю контроля получить. А ноды, чем они принципиально отличаются,
что весь процесс генерации — всё у тебя разложено по полочкам, всё видно в одном месте. Но давай
сразу покажу, что я подразумеваю под нодами, что это такое, как оно выглядит. Вот такой простой,
типичный нодовый граф. Какое-то изображение у нас входит, перекидывается дальше. Здесь нода,
которая просто через иишку описывает то, что у нас на изображении. Здесь, сразу скажу,
нодов предусмотрено огромное количество именно в VIVI. Дальше у нас две ноды, которые дорисовывают
вокруг исходного изображения. Всё остальное мы знаем, что это называется Outpaint. Вот здесь так это и
называется Outpaint. Перекидываем в эту ноду — это самое исходное изображение, логично. И дополнительно,
сюда ещё можно докинуть Prompt — описание того, что вообще на этом экране происходит. Это тоже полезно. Мы
тоже знаем, что это может быть полезным для Outpaint, чтобы консистентность у нас поддерживалась.
Соответственно, это описание из предыдущей ноды мы также сюда прикрепляем. Всё. Дальше у нас здесь две
разные модели: Flux, Stable Diffusion — это ноды конкретно Outpaint. Каждая из них делает этот Outpaint.
Дальше у нас нода Crop — то есть обрезать просто изображение. Дальше у нас нода с upscale. И исходники
мы закидываем в ноду, которая называется Compare — сравнить. Вот. То есть, видишь, здесь мы выстраиваем
процесс и по комбинации разных изображений, и по их редактированию, и по их иишной обработке,
то есть там upscale, сама по себе генерация, Outpaint и так далее. И каждый вот такой этапчик,
каждое вот это окошко — это нода. Нода по-английски — узелок. Соответственно,
вот есть у нас эта длинная верёвка и на ней отдельные узелки, в каждом из которых что-то
происходит. Если где-то на каком-то этапе у тебя что-то отвалилось, что-то пошло не так,
ты можешь это в одном месте поменять, проконтролировать, что теперь всё будет
правильно и генерировать сколько угодно раз. То есть, например, что делает этот pipeline?
делает Outpaint в двух разных редакторах, кропает оба изображения под 9 на 16 и сравнивает,
где получилось лучше. Соответственно, я теперь могу сюда закидывать на исходник просто какое
угодно изображение. Любого формата, любого цвета и так далее. Дальше весь pipeline будет
отрабатывать автоматически. Я закидываю изображение, на выходе получаю два дорисованных и
прообскеленных разными способами изображения. Ровно для этого нодами мы пользуемся. Один раз
выстроить pipeline и затем мучить его сколько угодно раз. И прежде чем продолжим, давай сначала
разделим, какие вообще ноды бывают. Их там просто огромное количество. Все запомнить и все здесь
сейчас тебе показать и объяснить невозможно. Мы будем стараться структурировать эту информацию. Я покажу
самое основное, но для того, чтобы прям вообще полностью всем этим управлять, нужно самостоятельно
тыкать, смотреть готовые примеры и только так что-то отложится. Если я просто озвучу для тебя
здесь вот такой справочник, ну это все равно в голове не отложится. Итак, какие у нас есть основные
группы? Первое - это вход и утильты. Это когда мы закидываем текст, правим текст, закидываем изображение,
его как-нибудь обрезаем, видео также там кропаем на отдельные кадры, склеиваем все это, накладываем друг на
друга и так далее. Это все такие маленькие утилитарные ноды, которые позволяют вносить новый контент вот в эту
всю среду, новый текст, новое изображение и как-то их базово обрабатывать без использования ИИ.
Следующие ноды - это генерации. Генерация видео, генерация текста, генерации 3d, ну и генерация самих изображений.
Следующая группа - это правки. Здесь у нас уже подключается ИИшка, но не обязательно. Это inpainting, outpainting, замена какой-то области,
маски, которые мы выделяем на изображения, в которых там потом inpainting, например, будет происходить, изменение освещения,
цвета и так далее. Это преимущественно ИИшные инструменты для редактирования. Дальше - улучшения. Тут, я думаю,
все понятно. Upscale мы его проходили. Отдельно у нас стоят спецноды для какого-нибудь липсинга, для создания
персонажей для видео, для каких-нибудь переходов и так далее. Их вообще может быть какое угодно количество.
Можно прям в комьюнити ноды создавать, и там таких инструментов, ну просто какое-то бесконечное количество. И последний
тип нодов - это вывод. Просто вывести то, что у тебя получилось, чтобы тебе было удобнее, нагляднее на это посмотреть.
Как видишь, сейчас, если все это структурировать, разложить не все так уж сложно. Самое основное - ноды,
которые редактируют, ноды, которые генерируют, и ноды, которые вносят правки. Все остальное используем не так часто.
Также, что еще важно отметить: у любой ноды есть вход и выход. То, что она получает и обрабатывает, и то,
что она дает. Это вот тоже нужно запомнить. Как правило, именно в виве с зеленым цветом у нас выход,
розовым цветом - вход. Сами эти переходы тоже могут быть по-разному окрашены. Здесь, например, у нас в виве
фиолетовым цветом переносится текст, зеленым кодируется изображение, белым могут кодироваться результаты
обработки, какие-то показатели, и вообще редко встречается. Если мы посмотрим, как это выглядит в Cree,
здесь тоже котировка цветами, просто уже другими цветами. Здесь, например, желтый - это текст,
изображение - это синий цвет, и розовый - это различные переменные, числовые значения и так далее.
Но точно так же тут все устроено по тому же принципу. Input, Output, входные, выходные данные. И прежде, чем мы
продолжим, давай поговорим о выборе инструмента. Я здесь уже тебе показал Cree, показал Figma VIV. Что, для чего мы
используем. Cree - это доступный, удобный инструмент, особенно учитывая, что у вас у всех уже есть Cree подписка. Это отличный
способ вкатиться, посмотреть, как это работает. Там хороший UI. Выглядит это все приятно, достаточно
интуитивно можно разобраться, но не все там всегда гладко работает. Некоторые ноды там, не знаю,
просто не запускаются. Многих нодов, которые хотелось бы там видеть, там нет. Хороший способ - попробовать,
посмотреть, как это работает, даже что-то собрать, действительно то, что будет работать. Но для профессиональной
полноценной работы лучше пользоваться Figma VIV. Там намного больше нод, работает это все быстрее.
моделей для генерации там тоже больше. И, на мой субъективный взгляд, как бы визуального мусора там меньше.
Из-за того, что больше нод, чуть менее отзывчивый UI, этот инструмент может показаться сложным. Но глобально
все-таки мне в нем работать проще. Но все-таки это отдельный инструмент, который покупается за отдельную подписку.
Только ради нодов, если тебе это не так нужно, ты можешь ее не покупать. Ознакомиться с этим процессом в Cree этого будет достаточно.
Ну а сейчас мы зайдем в Cree, соберем базовый pipeline, посмотрим, как это все работает,
как это все выглядит. И затем перейдем в Figma VIV, посмотрим уже примеры посложнее и соберем что-то интереснее.
Итак, когда мы только зашли в Cree, мы видим здесь нод-эдитор, можем сразу переходить смело в него и здесь
создавать новый workflow. Смотри, одна отличительная особенность Cree заключается в том,
что здесь можно с помощью UI сразу себе целый pipeline генерить. Не всегда он работает идеально,
не всегда он генерирует именно то, что тебе нужно, но все-таки я считаю это большой плюс.
Переходишь к агенту и ему надиктовываешь, как ты видишь свой pipeline. Он тебе его с нуля генерирует.
Если что-то не устроило, так же его можно помучить, он доработает.
Штука интересная, особенно если ты только вкатываешься в эти процессы, она может сильно помочь.
Но все-таки не настолько сложная тема, как может показаться лучше, на мой взгляд, самостоятельно по чуть-чуть идти и разбираться в этом.
Нам нужно начать с самой первой ноды Pkm и здесь мы можем выбирать какую ноду взять.
Здесь можем сразу посмотреть как раз таки разбиение на те группы, о которых мы ранее говорили:
Image, Video и другие. То есть утилитарные, либо предназначенные под какую-то узкую специфику:
сгенерировать 3D, аудио, ассеты, 3D объекты, мудборды. Мы уже знаем, где эти мудборды собираются и так далее.
Хотя на самом деле тут и вход-выход есть. В общем, все намешано.
Давай начнем с самой базы. Предположим, мы хотим сгенерировать изображение.
Pkm, Generate Image на вкладке Image и выбираем какую-нибудь любую модель.
Неплохо генерирует. Это все ровно те же самые модели, которые мы видели на вкладке.
Image, поэтому мы уже с ними более-менее знакомы, можем выбирать что угодно.
Ну, давай возьмем CRIA 2 Medium.
Возьмем CRIA 2 Medium. Здесь сразу отмечено, сколько токенов потратит 5 Compute Units.
Здесь у нас есть настройки.
Можем все это добавлять. По сути, то же самое, что у нас возникает, когда мы просто генерируем изображение.
Но, хотя здесь на самом деле этих полей больше. Давай пойдем по порядку.
Желтый цвет - это у нас текст.
Здесь у нас должен быть prompt для генерации изображения. Мы можем либо писать сразу тут, если хотим одно и то же генерировать,
либо можем зажать и создать новую ноду. Он здесь сразу предлагает текст.
И здесь писать, что у нас должно генерироваться.
Это удобно, когда ты хочешь просто таким образом вывести несколько текстовых полей,
править только их и весь остальной pipeline просто одной кнопкой запускать.
Итак, я хочу здесь, например, сгенерировать что-нибудь из того, что мне агент отдавал.
Вот у меня есть JSON Prompt готовый.
Просто скопирую его, вернусь к нодам и вставлю сюда.
Все. Дальше.
Здесь у нас мы можем выбирать стиль из тех, что мы создавали.
Здесь удобно, что если Vivi - это отдельная система со своей генерацией нодов и прочего.
Система сама на себе зацикленная.
То Cria здесь сразу имеет и отдельный enhancer, генерацию изображения, moodboard, стиль и так далее.
И твой вот этот нодовый редактор, он вписан в экосистему, в которой, возможно, ты большую часть времени будешь работать.
Это удобно.
Здесь также можем выбрать Style Image изображения, с которого стиль будет извлечен.
Добавить moodboard, который мы создавали.
Вот, например, Product Chat у меня есть.
Добавить негативный prompt, чего точно не должно быть на этом изображении.
Ну и все остальные настройки.
Обратите внимание, что здесь к этим числовым значениям подходят именно фиолетовые точки.
Я уже говорил, что фиолетовым цветом здесь кодируются различные переменные.
Если мы сейчас перетянем, он предложит нам создать вот как раз number.
Числовую переменную, пускай это, не знаю, 123, 20, 10 и так далее.
Таким образом, тоже отдельно можно все эти числовые переменные вынести, подрубить их к твоей ноде, закрыть это все и больше не вспоминать.
В случае, если что-то надо поменять, отдельно сюда зашли, поменяли.
Эти переменные могут на какое угодно количество разных нод пробрасываться.
Итак, есть у нас input, есть у нас наши ноды с изображением.
Запускаем процесс и генерируем какое-то изображение.
Вот, но получилось очень творчески.
Можем изменить prompt.
Смотри, еще что тебе нужно запомнить - это конкатенация.
Тут она в нодовых редакторах называется так.
По сути, конкатенация - это объединение разных кусков в одно целое.
Сейчас мы посмотрим, как это работает.
Здесь отключим prompt.
У меня описана только стилистика, цветовая палитра, освещение и так далее.
Ну, ты это все видел.
Я хочу также, чтобы у меня был какой-то другой объект.
Я могу сюда в этот джейсон-промпт добавить просто обжект, двоеточие и описание.
Но, чтобы просто посмотреть конкатенацию, нам будет удобнее сделать попроще.
Итак, правой кнопкой мыши.
Нажимаем конк, конкат текст, конкатенация, конкатенейт и так далее.
Точно так же это называется в виве.
И закидываем сюда все наши возможные импуты.
Вот у нас output второй.
Закидываем сюда.
Закидываем, добавляем еще одну ноду, в которой будет начало нашего промпта.
И опишем: сгенерирую ноутбук с этим стилем.
Двоеточие.
И дальше описан там стиль и все остальное.
Соответственно, когда мы перекидываем это дальше в промпт,
у нас объединяются вот эти два текстовых куска в нашем конкатенаторе.
Это можно вообще свернуть, чтобы оно больше тебе не мешало.
И видим, что конечный промпт у нас выглядит так:
generate laptop with the style:
и вот это все описание пошло.
Таким образом, мы можем вообще в принципе JSON промпты раскладывать,
чтобы удобнее с ними взаимодействовать,
чтобы каждый раз вот эти вот скобочки, точки и прочее не переиспользовать.
Сейчас покажу, как это делается.
Сначала давай еще один простой пример сделаем.
Например, каждый раз у меня будет один и тот же текст.
Здесь generate with the style.
Это будет повторяться, меняться.
Будет только объект, который я хочу сгенерировать.
Мы слишком ленивые для того, чтобы выделять конкретный кусок,
что-то тут менять.
Это неудобно.
Мы хотим, чтобы все было в одном окошке.
Без проблем.
Здесь мы вообще давай отрубим все эти подключения,
добавим еще один текст.
Текст у меня будет ну как бы object.
Я здесь поставлю laptop.
Теперь смотри, текст если будет один и тот же,
то нам нет смысла его отдельно выносить в ноду.
Поэтому берем вместе с пробелом, копируем generate,
вставляем сюда.
Сюда подкидываем следом после этого вот этот кусок текста с конечным продуктом.
И также вместе с пробелом остальную часть фразы копируем.
Вставляем сюда.
Добавляем еще один пробел.
И здесь в конец закидываем описание стиля.
И таким образом у нас получается generate laptop with the style.
То есть то же самое.
Но при этом вот эту фигню, она у меня статична.
Она у меня не меняется.
Здесь просто описание стиля.
Это мне больше не нужно.
Этот текст тоже статичен.
То есть стиль, ну там что-то может поменяться.
Вот эта фигня точно никак не изменится.
Все это закрываю, забываю об этом.
И в дальнейшем в одной и той же стилистике генерирую,
изображение чего угодно.
Лэптоп, маус, ноутбук там, ну короче, чего угодно.
Просто меняю здесь одно слово и каждый раз у меня будет получаться адекватный промт.
Давай сделаю, например, там не знаю, терминал.
Напишу терминал.
Generate.
Терминал.
Визы.
Стайл.
Добавлю тут, например, банкинг.
Терминал.
И у меня здесь этот промт меняется.
Все.
То есть мы также используем джейсон промт.
Но я в нем ничего не правлю.
Больше с ним не взаимодействую.
Не вижу там все эти кавычки и прочее.
Одно слово меняю.
Все.
Все готово.
А теперь мы склеили два разных куска.
Мы можем поступить еще хитрее.
Если мы посмотрим на этот промт, у нас здесь всегда вот эта кавычка открывается.
Style.
Двоеточие.
Еще одна кавычка открывается.
И длинное описание закрывается.
Mood.
И так далее.
Мы это можем точно так же разложить на статичные куски.
Закидываем просто первый кусок Style.
Знаем, что это будет статика.
Описание стиля подтягивается из отдельного блока, который будет называться у нас Style.
Все.
Он в конкатинатор добавляется.
После чего у нас дальше идет Mood.
Здесь предыдущую кавычку закрываем.
Добавляем эту запятую.
Добавляем этот перенос.
Просто вот этот кусок копируем вместе с этой кавычкой.
Вставляем.
И дальше нам нужно сюда только вводить адекватный текст.
Без всяких кавычек и так далее.
И здесь я последним добавил Object.
Сам объект, который будем генерировать.
Опять же у меня здесь это лаптоп.
И в конечном итоге я каждый из этих параметров вижу и могу нормально редактировать.
После чего этот результат у меня по разным нодам раскидывается.
Но тут я, например, хочу описывать на русском языке, чтобы мне было просто, понятно.
Возможно, я хочу делать это своими словами.
Можем отсюда это отрубить.
Здесь все это дело скрыть.
Нам не нужно, чтобы это мешалось.
И добавить еще одну ноду, которая называется LLM Call.
То есть вызов языковой модели.
На вход закидываем просто этот промпт.
А здесь в качестве систем промпта пишем:
«Ты должен просто переводить на английский язык».
Вот и весь его промпт.
После чего запускаем эту ноду.
И весь наш текст, который был на русском языке, просто языковая модель,
обычная, как ChatGPT, Gemini и прочее, переводит на английский язык.
Все.
Наш промпт здесь полностью переведен.
Готов к использованию.
Можем его прокидывать дальше.
Сюда во все остальные места, куда можем подрубить текстовый формат.
Все.
Точно так же это можно свернуть.
Оставить где-нибудь здесь.
И больше к этому не возвращаться.
Потом сгенерировали изображение.
Здесь вот этот у меня тот самый лаптоп.
Есть и остальные модели.
В них тоже попробовал сгенерировать.
Здесь результат мне нравится меньше.
Хотя нано-банано предыдущая тоже норм справилась.
Беру результат, который мне понравился.
и дальше с ним что угодно могу делать.
Есть разные утилитарные блоки.
Мы уже говорили о них.
Вот, например, Huey Saturation.
Цвет можно подогнать.
Попробовать какие-то другие, кстати, варианты.
Красный тоже неплохо выглядит.
Насыщенность там и так далее.
Все.
Запускаем ноду.
Он уже финализирует как бы это изображение.
И дальше в измененном виде мы его можем передавать.
Что еще можно сделать?
Например, можно сделать Upscale.
Upscale.
Мы здесь же делали Upscale.
Мы знаем уже, что Magnific - креативный.
Tapas - точный.
Faithful.
И здесь можем вообще этот Crea Enhancer, который копейки стоит,
сразу взять и настроить.
Все то же самое, что у нас там выводилось.
В конечном итоге в любой из нод можно это дело все просто скачать.
Также хотим что-то дорисовать.
Мы знаем, что у нас существует такое понятие, как InPaint - OutPaint.
Поэтому просто пишем вот, например, InPaint.
Честно, OutPaint тут как-то плохо работает.
Не всегда он запускается.
Поэтому сейчас давай посмотрим InPaint.
Выбираем его.
Когда мы говорили об InPaint, я упоминал, что это инструмент точечного редактирования какой-то области.
Соответственно, эту область нам нужно выделить.
И эта область у нас называется маска.
Соответственно, на вход у нас попадает изображение, которое мы будем редактировать.
И нам нужно также поместить туда маску.
Как мы это делаем?
Просто ищем соответствующую ноду.
Протягиваем.
Нам нужно там эту маску на этом изображении выделить.
Пишем mask.
И находим вот Image Mask Editor.
Берем его.
Чтобы нормально, корректно с этим всем работать,
здесь нажимаем развернуть на весь экран.
И выделяем, в какой области мы хотим работать.
То есть, саму область маски.
Например, хочу здесь это сделать.
Ну или давай, чтобы было нагляднее.
На самом ноутбуке нарисуем.
Через ластик сотрем это.
Добавим здесь.
Вот.
Тут я хочу расположить какой-нибудь цветок.
Нажму Done.
Сохраняется.
Все.
У нас отображается, что тут выделена маска.
Саму эту маску мы можем отдельно перекидывать.
Выбираем ее.
Закидываем сюда.
Все.
Он понимает, выделяет только отдельно этот кружок.
Понимает, в какой области ему нужно работать.
Чтобы мы закинули сразу целое изображение.
Он бы закинул все изображение с просто каким-то пятном.
Нам это точно не подходит.
Нам нужно работать именно с маской.
Все.
У нас есть исходник, на котором мы рисуем.
У нас есть область, выбранная на исходнике, в которой мы будем рисовать.
И теперь давай опишем, что там должно быть.
Я напишу стикер с цветком.
Все.
Aspect Ratio 1:1.
Запускаем ноду.
И смотрим, что у нас получается.
Все.
Он сгенерировал точечно в нужной области.
Сгенерировал этот цветок.
Подогнал его по перспективе.
В стилистику не очень он помещается.
Здесь этот промпт можно было бы расширить.
Точно так же через конкатенацию и так далее.
Но, я думаю, в целом принцип понятен.
Итак, InPaint посмотрели, Enhance посмотрели.
Генерацию изображений, конкатенацию посмотрели.
В целом, дальше процесс не сильно отличается.
С созданием видео и так далее.
Самую базу мы рассмотрели.
Я думаю, мы можем переходить в VIVI и посмотреть уже более интересный редактор.
Итак, VIVI по умолчанию на бесплатном аккаунте только при регистрации
и тебе дается сразу 150 токенов.
В рамках выполнения домашки тебе этого хватит с головой,
чтобы попробовать посмотреть, как это работает.
Если ты захочешь здесь курсовой проект выполнять,
то придется приобрести подписку.
Она стоит при помесячной оплате от 24 долларов в месяц.
Я использую вот эту базовую.
Мне ее хватает, чтобы комфортно работать.
Здесь у нас есть поисковик.
Можем выбирать любые ноды.
Тут их огромное количество, как я ранее говорил.
Быстрый доступ, самые базовые ноды Toolbox.
Дальше у нас тут уровни, каналы,
дефрагментация изображения по цветам, каналам.
Работа с альфа-каналами, с различными масками.
Масками через текст, масками через выделение области.
Короче, огромное количество здесь нодов.
Все их показать просто невозможно.
И 3D-модели тут тоже есть.
В конце у нас мои модели и модели комьюнити.
Здесь уже можно чужие модели использовать, чужие ноды.
Но, сразу скажу, не всегда они нормально работают.
Далеко не всегда.
Итак, давай попробуем преобразовать то изображение,
что у меня уже есть.
Правая кнопка мыши.
Импорт.
И закидываем сюда файлы, изображения и прочее.
В данном случае изображения.
Выберу C1.
Закидываю его сюда.
И теперь мы можем с ним работать.
По умолчанию точно так же перетягиваешь.
Он тебе предлагает, что можно использовать,
чтобы с этим изображением поработать.
Но, сразу отмечу, что не всегда он сюда выводит все, что тебе нужно.
Поэтому я зачастую просто правой кнопкой мыши через поисковик
выбираю ноды, которые я уже знаю, как называются.
Ну, либо по ключевым.
InPaint, OutPaint, Upscale и так далее словам.
Здесь, когда перетягиваешь, не всегда выпадает то, что тебе нужно.
Тут он почему-то сужает диапазон поиска.
Поэтому имей в виду, возможно, ты правильно пишешь название ноды.
Просто он здесь его не отображает.
У меня такое было несколько раз.
Я психовал, не понимал, в чем дело.
Итак, ну тут огромное количество различных нод.
Вот, например, какой-нибудь crop можем изображение обрезать.
Можем его там расширить.
Можем изменить его размер.
Можем отредактировать его по уровням.
Там выбрать канал, например, красный канал.
Изменить, настроить здесь цветокоррекцию.
Короче, в общем, возможностей здесь много.
Я хочу сейчас сделать OutPaint, потому что в Cree он не работает.
Хочу его сделать здесь.
Выбираю ноду OutPaint.
Здесь две вариации этой ноды.
Через Flux и через Stable Diffusion.
Stable Diffusion работает чуть-чуть быстрее.
Он немного дешевле.
Он здесь стоит 5 кредитов.
Здесь стоит 6 кредитов.
Учитывая, что у тебя 150 сразу бесплатно дается.
Я думаю, это неплохой запас.
Можно прокинуть сразу и здесь настроить, что я хочу конкретно расширить, на сколько и так далее.
Как я ранее говорил, будет не лишним здесь еще в Prompt указать, что у нас происходит на этом изображении.
Поэтому давай добавим точно так же нод LLM.
Выберем LLM, Run Any LLM.
Закидываем сюда.
И что у нас здесь получается?
System Prompt отдельно описываем.
Здесь мы можем выбрать LLM сразу, чтобы он это изображение описал.
То есть мы закидываем его на вход.
Здесь в System Prompt можем описать, что ты должен описывать изображения, должен описывать их определенным образом.
Но здесь уже есть для этого нод.
Он сразу предусмотрен.
Image Describer.
Выбрана модель Gemini.
Сразу расписано, как он должен описывать, что такое хорошее описание и так далее.
Поэтому просто прокидываем это сюда и на выходе получаем нормальное описание.
Подключаем его.
Запускаем всего лишь за один токен, за один кредит.
И описание нашего изображения готово.
Смотри.
У нас сейчас на экране всего 4 ноды.
Но уже сейчас это начинает выглядеть хаотичным, запутанным.
Что будет, когда у нас там их будет 10, 20, 30 штук.
Для этого есть отдельные утилитарные ноды, которые позволяют все это дело подсобрать.
Например, за теликом у тебя куча проводов.
Ты хочешь это все в один объединить.
Здесь для этого есть такая нода, которая называется роутер.
Ставим роутер.
И он, по сути, просто объединяет вот эти разные потоки.
И из него также ты их прокидываешь.
Вот, например, мы закинем это сюда.
Это все дело удалим.
Здесь точно также у нас идет разветвление.
Это можно убрать.
Создать еще один роутер.
И подкинуть сюда.
Этот поближе расположить сюда.
Здесь поставить на одном уровне это все.
Это подкинуть сюда.
И его как-нибудь тоже здесь на одной параллели.
Все.
У нас сразу все выглядит просто, красиво, аккуратно.
Возможно, на 4 нодах это не так заметно.
Но когда у тебя их становится много, тебе эта штука становится нужна.
Потому что отдельно ты будешь в сторону выносить то, что нужно редактировать.
От этого по всему экрану будут идти вот эти полоски.
И это все начнет мешать.
Ты начнешь путаться.
И так далее.
Говорю по собственному опыту.
Все.
Теперь в Outpaint.
Что мы можем выбрать?
Здесь у Flux и у Stable Diffusion разные настройки.
Тут либо сделать...
Здесь Flux позволяет либо только с одной стороны дорисовать, либо сделать Zoom Out.
Ну, давай выберем Zoom Out, чтобы у нас был запас.
И Stable Diffusion 3 позволяет отдельно с каждой стороны сколько угодно пикселей докидывать.
И плюс еще редактировать креативность.
Поставим 7 креативность.
Изображение у нас 16 на 9 исходник.
Поэтому здесь давай сверху добавим.
И снизу добавим, чтобы у нас получилось 9 на 16.
Все.
Запускаем эту ноду.
Запускаем эту.
И смотрим, что у нас получается.
Так, Stable Diffusion у нас дорисовал неплохо.
Но тут какие-то проблемы с пальцами.
Это можно отдельно через InPaint уже будет поправить.
А Flux Pro что-то очень сильно накреативил.
Можно запустить еще раз и посмотреть другой вариант исполнения.
Кстати, как раз посмотрим, как переключать исходное изображение.
Итак, тут он в очередной раз очень креативно дорисовал.
Здесь появилась какая-то голова, еще другие бумаги и так далее.
Но, в целом, моя задача была сделать из этого 9 на 16 изображение.
Мне и такого результата будет достаточно.
Теперь смотри.
Если у тебя внутри одной ноды несколько разных генераций, несколько вариантов,
ты выбираешь конкретный и он дальше двигается по твоему пайплайну.
Какой бы он по счету не был.
Первый, второй, четвертый из 100.
Если ты его здесь выбрал, именно он будет использоваться и дальше двигаться по твоему пайплайну.
Это мы запоминаем.
Дальше.
Я хочу это обрезать по-английски.
Обрезка - это crop.
Делаем crop image.
Здесь у нас 2x.
Здесь у нас zoom out 2x был.
Другого мы поставить не могли.
Давай выберем здесь 9 на 16.
Тот формат, который я хотел.
Кропнем так.
Все.
С этим изображением работать не очень удобно.
Поэтому есть отдельный нод, который называется превью.
Вот, кстати, как раз тот случай, когда нод наш по какой-то причине не появляется.
Можем его выбрать так.
Превью отдельно.
И сюда подкинуть.
Все.
Нод, который позволяет только посмотреть результат нашей генерации.
Чтоб нормально, удобно с ним ознакомиться, приблизить и так далее.
Все.
Теперь.
В sd3 outpaint мы тут рандомные значения выкручивали.
Просто чтоб вытянуть это изображение.
Нам нужно строго 9 на 16.
Поэтому, опять же, мы воспользуемся crop.
Возьмем crop.
Здесь ставим 9 на 16.
У нас, кстати, получается, что идеально получилось на глаз с первого раза сделать.
Ну, тут, да, немного есть зазор.
Но так практически идеально.
Также можем его перекинуть в ноду превью и посмотреть, что у нас получилось.
Также, если мы хотим сравнить, выбрать какой-то, какой нам больше понравился.
Добавить еще можно ноду compare.
Возьмем compare.
И сравним первое изображение со вторым.
Сюда это просто прокинув.
Все.
Через слайдер можем посмотреть, как у нас изображение меняется.
Сравнить, какое нам нравится больше.
И так далее.
То есть, не то чтобы это нода, которую ты будешь постоянно использовать.
Это просто говорит о том, насколько здесь нод много.
Насколько много сценариев здесь предусмотрено.
И это, конечно, очень круто.
Следующее, что я хочу тебе показать, это итераторы.
Мы тут все дизайнеры знаем, что такое итерации.
Если не знаем, то это прогоны, повторения и так далее.
Ну, в общем, сейчас более предметно посмотрим, как это работает.
Смотри.
Предположим, у меня есть вот этот json prompt,
который описывает стиль моего изображения.
Хочу скопировать это.
Возвращаюсь в Google Chrome.
Здесь добавляю этот самый prompt.
Вставляю сюда.
Все.
Он, кстати, здесь сразу воспринимает его как json.
Но, имея в виду, что когда передаешь это в разные модели,
он может капризничать, мол, наши модели такое не съедают.
Можно просто здесь выставлять текст, и они json будут все запросто съедать.
Вот мой json prompt.
Я сюда только хочу добавить еще строку объект и менять этот объект на разные.
Поэтому точно так же добавляем сюда конкатенатор и собираем наш prompt.
Итак, первую часть добавляем.
Из нее мы извлекаем самый конец.
Сюда добавляем запятую.
А дальше, что я хочу, сюда же добавить вот этот кусок.
Вместе с запятой выделим и до кавычек скопируем.
Все, вставляю это сюда.
Здесь это убираю.
У нас остается object, кавычки, двоеточие.
Дальше.
Сюда мы вставляем уже какое-то описание объекта.
Сам наш объект.
Мы видим, что у нас это появилось.
И добавляем еще один текст input, который будет оставшуюся часть закрывать.
Тут у нас только двойная кавычка и фигурная скобка.
Все.
Получился prompt, стиль, описание.
Все это есть.
Object.
Сюда он встроен.
Все.
Теперь этот объект мы можем менять.
Вот эту штуку можно оставить.
Нас это все не интересует.
Можно это здесь все собрать.
Мы будем менять здесь только сам объект.
И здесь в этой ноде у нас еще есть возможность дополнительно что-то дописать.
То, что не будет меняться.
Но здесь я смысла в этом не вижу.
Все.
Весь prompt мы передаем со стилем, с описанием объекта и так далее.
И можем генерировать в Nano Banana 2.
Даже с подпиской в Cree это значительно дороже выходит.
Тут полторы тысячи токенов на самые дешевые подписки.
И генерация одна в Nano Banana 6 кредитов стоит.
Ну, это небо и земля вообще по стоимости.
Итак, например.
Хочу я сгенерировать свой лэптоп.
А в следующий раз я хочу сгенерировать мобильный телефон.
А потом вообще какой-нибудь торшер или планшет.
Торшер или планшет.
И так далее.
А может быть я за раз хочу и торшер, и мобильный телефон, и планшет.
И каждый раз писать, ждать пока сгенерируется.
Ну, было бы странно.
Да, это было бы долго и неудобно.
Давай сначала попробуем сгенерировать этот лэптоп, который у нас уже есть.
Вот.
Сгенерировал лэптоп.
Да, стилистика наша.
Узнаваемая.
Кстати, интересное получилось изображение.
Теперь, что же все-таки, если я хочу кучу разных устройств нагенерировать, сразу пак ассетов с разным наполнением и так далее.
Тут как раз таки нам нужна нода итератор.
Текст итератор, имидж итератор.
Если у тебя текстовые вводные могут быть разные, то текст итератор.
Если ты от изображения отталкиваешься, закидываешь сюда изображение, то точно так же итерации ты можешь делать с ними.
В этом текст итераторе добавляем наши элементы.
Например, таблет, мобайл фон.
И смотри, если я сейчас выберу здесь генерацию, то он показывает, что стоить она будет 6 кредитов.
Если здесь у нас в качестве вводной будет не просто лэптоп, а итератор, то стоимость уже изменится.
Причем, даже если вот сейчас мы подключим сюда напрямую, он показывает 2 values, 2 значения.
Через текст итератор подключен, поэтому будет 12 кредитов.
Потому что я буду генерировать 2 раза по 6.
Если мы будем по ходу цепочки прежде где-то подключать этот итератор,
если мы по ходу цепочки будем подключать до генерации изображения этот итератор,
то это точно так же будет работать.
До этого текст у нас заходил сюда.
Теперь мы закидываем его сюда.
Это мы отсюда удалим.
И так же, как раньше, подключим сюда.
Также он видит, что у нас 2 values.
Этот объект, сколько бы их не было, будет проходить через этот конкатенатор
и генерировать уже в формате полноценного промта.
Здесь можно это немного изменить по последовательности, чтобы удобнее было.
И таким образом, сколько угодно айтемов мы можем добавлять.
Также, смотри, если мы это сейчас отсюда удалим и здесь опишем все через запятую и закинем в текстовый итератор,
то здесь у нас появляется split text by.
По какому символу нужно текст разделять.
У нас здесь все идет через запятую и после этой запятой еще пробел.
Поэтому ставим запятую, пробел, нажимаем enter.
И у нас в этом итераторе автоматически наш текст, наше перечисление разбивается на разные итерации.
Идет дальше и тут у нас уже 3 values, 3 различные генерации.
Если мы совсем обленились, то что мы можем сделать?
Закидываем еще сюда LLM, system prompt, закидываем отдельно.
Ты генерируешь на английском языке перечисление различных аппаратов.
В ретро стиле какие-нибудь там большие мониторы и так далее.
Можно как угодно описывать.
Один аппарат, запятая, один аппарат, запятая.
В таком формате тебе нужно генерировать 5 аппаратов.
Закидываем, пускай он думает над этим.
Эту штуку вообще тут можно удалить, отсоединить от всего.
Это перекинем пока не в system prompt, а просто в prompt.
Чуть позже покажу зачем.
Итак, все.
Он генерирует, делает это через Gemini 3 Pro.
Также всего один кредит на это уходит.
Все.
Он нас послушал, генерирует эти аппараты.
Также перекидываем, разделяем через запятую с пробелом.
Все.
У нас 5 разных аппаратов.
Выйдет у нас генерация.
Вот 30 кредитов.
Запускаем.
Все.
Он в одной стилистике автоматически делает из этих 5 объектов изображение.
Также мы можем здесь даже унифицировать это еще сильнее.
Ты генерируешь на английском языке перечисление различных аппаратов в ретро стиле.
Мы можем сделать различных объектов.
Ты генерируешь на английском языке перечисление различных объектов по той теме, что указано в prompt.
Один объект, запятая, один объект, запятая.
В таком формате тебе нужно генерировать три варианта.
Мы это теперь в качестве системного promptа подключаем, потому что это описание его поведения.
А здесь мы будем писать вообще какую угодно тематику.
Ну бытовая техника.
Максимально ленимся.
Придумываем только тематику того, что нужно генерировать.
Закидываем сюда.
Запускаем также модель.
Он генерирует эти описания.
И здесь у нас уже прошла генерация с этими нашими ретро объектами.
Выглядят они классно.
Давайте через превью посмотрим, как это будет выглядеть.
Итак, здесь тем временем у нас уже сгенерировались вот эти наши ретро объекты.
Через превью можем посмотреть их поудобнее.
Обрати внимание, что когда ты действуешь итерацией, у тебя сразу пачка сюда выкидывается.
Ну, тут это так и называется.
Бэтч.
Вот.
Такие получились изображения.
Здесь мы также можем переключать их.
Блин, получилось очень классно.
И в нашей стилистике.
Каждая из них выглядит консистентно, похожа друг на друга.
Даже если что-то немного выбивается, всего лишь еще один раз перегенерировать,
и будет уже отлично это выглядеть.
Вот эта, кстати, штука мне особенно нравится.
Итак, по сути, мы выстроили конвейер вот таких бесконечных вариаций.
Сколько угодно будет придумывать эти аппараты.
Какие-то осциллографы, ленты, тумблеры, пленки и так далее.
Это сколько угодно уникального контента, который в одной и той же стилистике,
который самостоятельно делает ИИШКО.
Если хотим поменять тематику, пожалуйста, бытовая техника, рефрижератор, стиралка, микроволновка.
Все, он это все автоматически прогоняет, закидывает и точно так же генерирует.
Итак, я показал тебе самое основное, где можно посмотреть еще подробнее готовые варианты.
Возвращаемся на самый главный экран.
И здесь сверху их просто огромное количество.
Это и генерация иллюстраций, готовый пайплайн, и изменение там угла камеры, и преобразование изображения в 3D.
Короче, огромное количество здесь уже готовых пайплайнов, которые ты можешь посмотреть, разобрать и запомнить, как это работает, как собирать это самостоятельно.
Мы посмотрели все основные ноды, мы посмотрели, как это работает, поэтому тут у тебя 90% всех вопросов уже должно быть закрыто.
Здесь у нас, например, отдельно вынесено, какие у нас персонажи, закинут изображения референсы, объединены в style guide, описание стиля.
Точно так же у нас просто reference image описывается, затем ты пишешь, сколько нужно иллюстраций.
Также через конкатенатор prompt это все объединяется, преобразуется в нормальный prompt через LLM.
Мы все это делали.
Array тоже делали.
В этой штуке смысла нет, поэтому мы ее не смотрели.
Роутер мы тоже смотрели, как сделать, чтобы все объединить, как сделать, чтобы все удобно объединить.
То есть, например, если сейчас это бы все шло из этого фрейма, то тут целых 6 или 8 вот этих вот связей по всему нашему графу распределялись, было бы неудобно.
Ну и в конечном итоге в одной и той же модели он одновременно генерит несколько изображений.
Здесь на самом деле вот это перечисление, это такой рудимент, разбиение на отдельные окна, учитывая, что ты в одной и той же модели генерируешь, тоже смысла никакого нет.
Инструмент развивается, поэтому возможно такое, что непонятно, зачем вообще нужны те или иные ноды, или почему здесь в примере это собрано так.
Но в большинстве случаев собрано здесь все отлично, показательно, удобно, поэтому, пожалуйста, ознакомливайся.
Все самое основное ты уже знаешь.
На этом все, осталось только выполнить домашнее задание, закрепить тот материал, который у нас сегодня был.
Урок получился один из самых длинных, потому что инфы действительно много.
Самое основное мы теперь знаем, но, конечно, в этих нодах можно развиваться бесконечно, там еще очень много всего, если копнуть.
Итак, в качестве домашнего задания тебе нужно собрать нодовую модель в крие, либо в вив и собрать модель достаточно простую.
Во-первых, добавить ноду с промптом, с описанием твоего изображения.
Добавить несколько нодов с генерацией изображения.
Там, ChatGPT, NanoBanano, Flux, какие угодно на свой вкус.
И добавить ноду Upscale, в которой ты подключишь ту ноду, в которой получился самый классный вариант.
Пора обскилить это изображение.
И на этом все.
Чтобы сдать домашнее задание, просто скидываешь ссылку на проект, либо скринишь его полностью, вот этот нодовый пайплайн, и отправляешь в зан-классе.
На этом все.
Удачи с выполнением домашнего задания и увидимся в следующем уроке.